bonobo or pan paniscus is a kind of
April ated to the chimpanzee that lives
in the Democratic Republic of Congo a
bonobo is also a star in the new sci-fi
summer blockbuster dawn of the Planet of
the Apes does it look like this to be a
sequel to 2011's Rise of the Planet of
the Apes and prequel to please don't
make anymore Planet of the Apes the
movie was raked in a hundred and four
million dollars worldwide in its opening
weekend features chimps going apeshit on
San Francisco which might help us forget
Charlton Heston making out with an egg
lady in the 1968 original the bonobo and
the latest flick is Koba a ruthless
scarred CGI'd primate played by actor
Toby Kebbell koba's harsh days as a lab
subject have driven him to seek revenge
against the fuzz Liss who wronged him
but some audience members are perturbed
they point out that in real life bonobos
are actually nonviolent in real life
they also don't ride horses but who's
keeping track bonobos unlike other
primates don't wage war on their fellow
bonobos and live in matriarchal
communities strange since bonobos and
chimps are more closely related to
humans than any other species on earth
we share almost 99% of our DNA with them
the 1% difference could account for this
this and of course this bonobos on the
other hand are known as the make love
not war Apes a phrase they live by and
also unlike other primates bonobos do it
for pleasure a whole lot they're also
the only Apes known to have sex in the
missionary position not to mention many
others Cosmo magazine would love to
learn about scientists think that
bonobos use sex to maintain social bonds
and avoid conflict
aka makeup sex Susan Bloch a
self-described sexologist was so upset
at the new film's portrayal that she
wrote that she's starting a bonobo
anti-defamation league
to speak out against the misleading
defamatory poor trails of bonobos and
the media valiant cause Susan
but if Renault Bo's really could talk
they'd probably say hey maybe you could
stop poaching us for meat and clear
cutting our forests man bonobos are
endangered and their numbers have been
shrinking for the last thirty years
thanks to hunting human war and the
destruction of their rainforest habitat
which means ko vine the dawn of the
Planet of the Apes isn't too far off
humans really are the threat so don't
hate bonobos appreciate
you